[Musique]
le père noël et puis pour elle un sac
et puis après
si tout est accordé au père noël celle
qui dans ce match rappelle plus fillon
incarne ol s il ya le relais
et grosse bise s'il a envoyé jean papa
noël je m'appelle christine j'ai 4 ans
j'essaie d'être gentil voici ce que je
voudrais pour noël c'est simple tout est
indiqué même le prier sans milette sont
déjà parvenues au centre des postes de
libourne certaines même en provenance de
l'étranger beaucoup d'envois collectifs
aussi des dessins extraordinaires
réalisés en classe
[Musique]
oh
et en particulier ceux qui nous parvient
avec même à l'intérieur un cadeau pour
le père noël
l'idée certainement venue des enfants
puisque il nous expédie des friandises
avec le souvenir et la description de
l'enfant qui nous l'a renvoyé
[Musique]
la publicité qui a pris droit de cité
évidemment chez les enfants aussi et il
est une habitude qui se perpétue qui
consiste à découper le catalogue à le
coller directement sur la sueur a
demandé au père noël ce qui évite bien
sûr à celui ci bien des hésitations
oui pas rater jouer la poupe est talonné
de près par tous les jeux vanté par la
télévision mais triste influence aussi
de l'actualité
eric 9 ans je voudrais une rampe de
lancement de missiles ou
[Musique]